non je voudrais en venir maintenant à
l'anniversaire demain des deux ans de
l'occupation par les sans papiers de
l'église saint-bernard à la veille des
différentes manifestations nous avons
voulu savoir ce qu'étaient devenus
certains de ces sans papiers
l'exemple de ces personnes l'une a été
régularisée notre pas emilie lançant luc
bachofen magot est une ancienne de saint
bernard
elle a été régularisée il ya deux ans
juste après l'évacuation de l'église
à 22 ans mais bouffé des ménages et son
mari tient la planche dans un restaurant
tous deux ont des fiches de paye et
leurs enfants vont à l'école
ils vivent à quatre dans une même pièce
ici dans un immeuble du 10e
arrondissement occupé depuis un an par
le collectif saint bernard
si tout n'est pas facile avoir des
papiers a changé leur vie salah 5
beaucoup de sauce même on peut s'y
promener
ça c'est quelque chose qu'ils savent ça
parce que ici tous les endroits qui
étaient par ces salaires pas pire que
des mâles moment même où puisqu'il les
enfants de quoi ils demandaient la
papier si tu n'as pas les papes et des
emplois il va parler à l'écran sur les
300 sans-papiers qui avait investi
saint-bernard 17 m'ont pas été
régularisée dia gif et par type cela il
est frappé d'une interdiction territoire
et son dossier l'un des plus compliqués
marié et père d'un enfant né en france
il a été expulsé en mali après saint
bernard moi ils m'ont expulsé mais moi
pas mais elle est restée là avec
neuf ans nationaux étaient là bas les
familles janv ier mon appareil ma
famille
la plaie
ceux qui ont été régularisés comme comme
des aides les autres comme à l'origine
du mouvement le mot d'ordre est des
papiers pour tous on a toujours
haudiquet bombay temps qui reste un sans
papiers de saint bernard qui n'a pas été
régularisée la lutte de saint-bernard ça
continue s'ils veulent king que la lutte
des saint-bernard et paraître une idée
de régulariser tous les sans papiers
sans perdre son âme alors là on n'en
parle plus
je connais est une enfant de saint
bernard elle est née le 17 août six
jours avant l'expulsion de l'église pour
être française à l'âge de 13 ans elle
devra faire une demande de nationalité